>> Hello Neotoy and the rest of the YouTube
community. I did listen to part of your complaints
about that we need to develop other measures
of say human progress or happiness or whatever.
The GDP is too restricted. That is true. Gross
Domestic Product, as you refer really measures
a lot of the staff available economy. The
new economy, if you take that innovation and
things like that, the service sector isn't
adequately reflected in that and if you broaden
it further than that, we are trying to develop
the UN system and others much broader index.
There is probably for example by the UNDD,
the United Nations Development Program every
year, the Human Development Index, where one
tries to look at how countries progress across
a very broad range of different things, be
that health or social indicators, environmental
indicators. I don't think happiness is really,
we haven't found a way of measuring happiness.
But much broader measurements of the way which
society's progress, that's called for and
that's just circumstance on the way.